Germany spends a great deal of time and
energy examining its Nazi past but when
it comes to the former East Germany
young Germans are more likely to think
of the German Democratic Republic as a
quirk of history a goofy and distant
failed experiment in socialism with
kitschy products and nude beaches recent
TV visited Berlin on the 25th
anniversary of the fall of the Berlin
Wall and asked Berliners about the
disparity and reflection of its two most
recent errors of tragic totalitarianism
as a definite life threatened him not
assist him on the immunization system
the essentially specialist vermin HD
stallion cited as a villain on short a
bird song of the day a blink touch
varnish finish author filete song is the
discuss your NIA it has been less than a
generation since the Wall fell and
nowadays a lot of young people don't see
communism and totalitarianism as a part
of our very recent past but they see it
as some really historic ancient thing
the Bauder brothers the artists behind
the central art installation
commemorating the 25th anniversary of
the fall of the Berlin Wall
think the difference is less political
and more geographical today we have 80
million inhabitants 20 20 million of
them were from are from the east or have
backgrounds in the east
for them it's it's there every day but
for the 60 million on the west side if
you don't have any personal connection
if you don't have friends have families
in the East it's far far away because
the Western system survived our Germany
or people in Germany deal of the past is
I think it depends on your personal
connection to the topic young people
from the West they never actually learn
about it because they had nobody in the
family who could tell them about it and
a lot of people the East got this notion
that it wasn't so bad after all
nostalgia for the East known as a stodgy
survives both as a fashion statement and
a desire to return to a supposedly
simpler time the security you had as
everything was set up for you everything
was taken care of and people just forget
the terror of this regime and they
forget twenty-five years ago people
actually went out on the street and
risked their lives because they couldn't
stand anymore being under the
surveillance and watch 24 hours a day
living under the threat
of being imprisoned being tortured or
even being shot when wanting to leave
the country they totally forgot that and
it's terrible that in Germany there's
not a proper education on the terrors of
communism a lot of people tend to
euphemized accruals of East Germany like
a thousand people died trying to escape
this country many many more were in
prison because they dare to speak up
communism socialism still has a very
positive notion in broad parts of the
German society in the East but also in
the West this promise of paradise on
earth actually can only be bought by the
price of terror and of suppression and
of a regime that won't let people live
their own lives but dictates how a good
life looks like though the terrors of
the GDR might not be everyday
conversation in Germany physical
reminders of this bizarre and tragic
period remains scattered throughout
Berlin I think it's very important that
we still have some remainders of the
wall in Berlin it shows us what a lot of
people died for and fought for for
freedom for freedom of movement for
freedom of expression so all over Berlin
you can see little markers on day on the
street on the pavement which illustrate
where the wall separated this beautiful
city into two parts into two regimes and
actually two two worlds freedom and
Torterra totalitarianism so maybe the
most important thing we can learn about
the events twenty-five years ago
the demonstrations here in Berlin it
depends always on people fighting for
freedom that freedom is established in
an open society only lives by those
fighting for it
you